[Musique]
donc atteint
dans les faubourgs d'islamabad une
journée spéciale à temps ses élèves des
bidonvilles alentours leur école a
invité un compteur à salavaux les corps
et
ce jour là c'est l'histoire du petit
prince d'antoine de saint-exupéry que le
compteur d'un arrêt en ourdou la langue
nationale du pakistan
wipolo
groupe soudé
où on se doit d'avoir des côtes moscow
des
bretons marot c'était très bien le
conteur me mets toutes les scènes et
jouer des personnages différents c'était
drôle
davidas un scandale est envoyé par story
quitte une maison d'édition spécialisée
dans les contenus interactifs comme
support éducatif
lorsque les enfants écoutent des
histoires il se met à les visualiser et
cela développe leur créativité nous ne
savons pas combien de ces enfants ici
deviendront des écrivains des artistes
ou des scientifiques mais pour leur
avenir c'est important qu'ils sortent
des sentiers battus et l'écoutent
d'histoire aide à cela
des outils auxquels ces enfants n'ont
pas accès leur école gérée par une ong
pakistanaises veut changer leur destin
l'organisation se donne pour mission de
scolariser les enfants des rues
[Musique]
vous voyez ce livre d'histoire grâce à
ce livre d'histoire nous avons appris à
nos enfants à mesurer leurs parents
n'ont pas les moyens d'acheter ses
livres mais nous avons ces ouvrages ici
dans les écoles et les enfants la
possibilité de les consulter certains
des enfants les plus âgés emporte ses
livres à la maison elise les histoires à
leurs petits frères et soeurs des livres
pour enfants ou les services d'un
compteur cette école publique en plein
air n'y songe même pas elle n'en a pas
les moyens les élèves ici doivent
installer eux-mêmes le matériel pour la
classe qui se déroule sous cet arbre la
moitié des enfants suit un cours de
religion tandis que l'autre apprendre la
grammaire le mollet du village assure
les cours depuis 23 ans
notre salaire est de 40 euros par mois
et l'état nous donne aussi 5 euros
mensuels pour la gestion de l'école
mais nous n'avons rien reçu depuis huit
mois ces enfants sont tous pauvres il
n'y aucune autre école ici alors on
continue de leur enseigner c'est comme
un devoir envers notre société
44% des enfants entre 5 et 16 ans ne
vont pas à l'école au pakistan autrefois
les compteurs traditionnels joué un rôle
direct dans l'éducation informelle
ils ont d'ailleurs été très populaire à
partir du xvième siècle voici l'un de
leur ancien qg le bazar de qui sarhani
traduction le marché des conteurs
d'histoires dans l'ouest du pays
et et chats malines et commerçants dans
le quartier
c'est dans ce genre de salon de thé
traditionnel que les compteurs narry
leur histoire
racontant une histoire
voyons comment je pourrais vous raconter
une histoire tous les compteurs sont
morts
dans le passé les commerçants indiens en
route pour l'asie centrale et ceux
d'afghanistan alors en inde faisaient
une halte ici il racontait les histoires
de leur pays ou de leurs ancêtres cet
endroit est devenu le lieu des changes
de légende à l'époque contemporaine
cette tradition est morte et les
histoires contées ont aussi disparu car
personne ne les a retranscrite
ailleurs dans le pays certains temps de
perpétuer la tradition
quelques-uns viennent des montagnes
isolées du nord où les traditions
perdurent nous a fallu ramener l'un
d'eux il rend visite à sa famille
installée près de la capitale quand nous
le rencontrons et comme il le fait
chaque soir au village il narre ici
aussi les légendes ancestrales
non seulement
ces histoires sont importantes parce
qu'elle raconte ce qui s'est vraiment
passé
ce sont des histoires
je ne crois pas à ces choses là ce sont
des légendes
et ils sont attirés par les films et les
chances sont indienne et ils ne sont
intéressés que par ça il n'écoute pas
les conseils de leurs grands parents de
leurs parents quand quelqu'un raconte
des histoires comme celle-là il tourne
la tête et regarde leur téléphone
portable
avec les réseaux sociaux et les
nouvelles technologies les compteurs
traditionnels disparaissent peu à peu au
pakistan est avec eux leur récit car
rares sont les légendes qui ont été
retranscrites